here is marjorie taylor green herself  take a listen not only do we have the dc  jail which is the dc gulag but now we  have nancy pelosi's gazpacho police  spying on members of congress fine  oh man if you missed it here it is one  more time  which is the dc gulag but now we have  nancy pelosi's gazpacho police spying on  members of as alexandria ocasio-cortez  tweeted  this is what happens when you ban books  from your house  uh this woman has gone completely lentil  i'm sorry mental i'm sorry now i'm  getting all soup soup confused no i mean  listen it's uh  as a reminder the gestapo was the german  secret police of the nazis in third  reich  world war ii era germany gazpacho is a  vegetable  tomato  cold soup typical in spain